Another Thing That Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed
to do At the SCP Foundation: Dr. Bright is
not allowed anywhere near a Renaissance Festival,
especially not with D-class in garb.
The SCP Foundation has some of the most high-tech
equipment you’ve ever seen - Or rather,
never seen.
After all, they’re working with unimaginable
supernatural power, and they need the very
cutting edge in technology to keep all these
anomalous powers contained.
But of course, this can make Foundation employees
long for a simpler time.
However, that’s no excuse for Dr. Bright
to lead a band of D-Classes in medieval garb
- Many of which, by the way, are convicted
killers - to a local Ren Faire.
This has, on multiple occasions, led to fires,
assaults, property damage, and death - Some
of which came from curious Ren Faire attendants
touching Dr. Bright’s medallion to see if
it was real.
Naturally, the Foundation isn’t eager to
see this kind of history repeat itself.